bonsoir mesdames bonsoir mesdemoiselles
messieurs bonsoir nous aurions aimé en
ce soir de réveillon
en cette veille de noël vous présenter
un journal totalement différent de nos
émissions habituelles nous devrions vous
de vous présenter uniquement des
séquences amusante drôles ou charmante
mais ce n'est pas nous qui commanderont
à l'actualité
elle est ce qu'elle est si je puis
réduire au strict minimum les
informations politiques
je vous demande d'abord de regarder
ensemble les premières images qui nous
parviennent de la catastrophe du
lacanien mais ces images en cette soirée
de noël ils ont une signification toute
particulière vous le savez c'était la
croisière du réveillon plus de 1000
personnes l'avait espéré souhaitez-vous
lui attendu préparer et puis tout s'est
terminé dans un tourbillon de flammes
dans une course folle à la vie dans la
panique les cris peut être des bagarres
car sur ce bateau en feu il y a eu
panique lorsque les premières fumées ont
léché les embarcations de sauvetage
c'est cette panique plus que la mère qui
a tué 70 80 90 personnes on ne sait pas
exactement encore qu'un des bilans ne
concorde le bateau malgré les
affirmations de la compagnie n'était pas
un navire sûr on raconte qu'au cours
d'une croisière déjà le feu s'était
déclaré quatre fois il n'y avait pas à
bord d'un système automatique de
repérage et de lutte contre l'incendié
mais il ya plus grave encore les
rescapés accuse l'équipage s'est affolé
les officiers ont disparu certains ont
poussé les passagers hors des canaux
personne ne diriger la manoeuvre
d'abandon il n'y avait pas de vivre dans
les canaux les pompes ne fonctionnait
pas la compagnie répond nous n'avons pas
reçu le rapport pas de commentaire
ce soir à minuit le laconia flambera
encore autour de lui les épaves
un porte-avions américain de remorques
officiellement les opérations de
recherche sont terminés tout être vivant
est en sécurité à bord des navires
sauveteurs dans deux heures 300 d'entre
eux arriveront à casablanca ce matin 400
sont déjà arrivés à madère pour eux qui
sont passés si près de la mort noël sera
bien sûr la fête de l'espérance la plus
belle de toutes les fêtes en hongrie
catastrophe de chemin de fer 36 morts
sont à déplorer politique après les
accords de bruxelles d'hier satisfaction
dans tous les pays membres du marché
comme à washington
la chambre a voté la loi sur l'aide à
l'étranger
c'est un très grand succès de prestige
pour le président johnson et facilitera
entre autres les achats de blé russe aux
états unis voient et maintenant nous
allons passer à la deuxième partie de ce
journal télévisé un peu spéciale et j'ai
demandé un mais bon confrères de
présenter cette émission avec moi c'est
un journaliste charmant sympathique le
plus jeune de tous le plus impartial et
qui je crois connaît admirablement son
métier mur supporteront voyons une
grande nouvelle
le tchèque ont décidé de réduire de 5 mm
la longueur des allumettes
économie un demi hectare de forêt par an
les ours de tchécoslovaquie s'en
réjouissent et moi aussi
didon lyon elle qui reçut de demain
le tiercé de manos je préparais le
journal télévisé moi je n'ai pas eu le
temps de regarder les journaux de course
travail travail ton journal ma pauvre
petit amie claudia cardinale pour les
intimes a été mordu par une méchante
fusionnent à robben en espagne
rassurez-vous la lionne est indemne
c'est une brave bête a déclaré ma petite
amie claudine à la lionne a pour prénom
également claudia qui n'ont leone et le
tiercé de demain eh ben je travaille
north je travaille du seuil à 20
partants c'est difficile oui c'est
difficile
avis à tous les petits enfants si vous
sortez couvrez vous bien car il fait
très froid et dites à vos parents d'être
très prudents en voiture à l'office
météorologique annonce de la neige et du
verglas sur toutes les routes de france
et il y en a des accidents prudence le
petit
qui dont lyon le terrain demain il va
être sûrement dure sera peut-être glisse
au times et bac tu ailles faut attendre
on saura ça demain matin c ac est
difficile aux courses je vais te donner
les gagnants l'instant information de
dernière minute des petits enfants d'une
école de palerme ont expédié hier de
jolies petites charrettes sicilienne
plein de joujoux et de fruits ils en
font cadeau à meschers petit ami john
john et caroline kennedy avec une belle
neutre et moi je leur dis spécial mot
bon noël petit jaune jaune et petite
caroline qui l'ont lyon tu l'as trouvé
le tueur sud mais j'en ai trouvé deux
sur trois orphéon l aile comme louis et
aux banques de courcelles parce que
j'habite non loin de la rue de
courcelles et toi qu'est ce que tu
apprends moi je vois no no no no de sacy
ortiz à ortisei 1e août seuls outils
d'air ça nous en fait 5 à nous de 10
dans aujourd'hui le monde dont tu va
fêter d'horreur
et dans le monde entier des millions de
personnes ont préparé la crèche
c'est ici à bethléem que se trouvait il
y à bien longtemps
celle de l'enfant juste il y à bien
longtemps mais depuis dans le monde
entier on a trouvé d'autres crèches plus
belles les unes que les autres et ce
soir pour tous les enfants qui nous
écoutent
nous allons faire un grand voyage pour
voir ensemble comment dans le monde on
prépare ce fameux nay
et pour commencer ce voyage prenons
l'avion avec bonhomme de neige il nous
sera le bonjour de la france au monde en
liesse et cette chaîne de l'amitié que
rien ne serait brisée
ni les océans ni les montagnes ni la
couleur de la peau puisque nous voici
déjà en afrique à nairobi où l'on
prépare l'événement fiévreusement les
paquets vont se transformer en cadeau
sur un arbre de lumière
et voici rio l'amérique latine la foule
la couleur l'ambiance chaude et vivante
des veilles de fêtes tout près à
copacabana les trois rois mages statufié
font leur révérence sur l'herbe fraîche
les petits allemands eux ont beaucoup de
chance
on raconte que là bas il arrive de
rencontrer le père noël dans les trams
et pour une fois parce que c'est noël et
parce qu'on est bien sage pour une fois
on peut lui parler
même quand il conduit en norvège quand
on est bien sarge on peut jouer avec le
père noël un merveilleux jeu de cache
cache dans la nuit dans la nef s'est dit
on un père noël très jeune et en suède
par contre il vaut mieux écrit dehors il
fait trop froid pour les petits enfants
et papa noël envoie ces facteurs admis
les parents préfèrent
l'année dernière en suède
aucune lettre ne s'est perdu des enfants
qui chantent dans la clairière
ensoleillé c'est le soleil de l'amitié
de longue aaron tous rescapés de la
fureur meurtrière du barrage en folie
ils sont venus chercher dans les
dolomites un arbre un grand sapin de
noël pour l'ériger sur la place du
village et pour souhaiter dans un baiser
un joyeux noël à tous les enfants
malades
à londres aussi on pense à eux sur le
parvis de la tricentenaire cathédrale
saint paul une fillette est venu
apporter son offrande pour que les
petits enfants et chaud au coeur cette
nuit partout à moscou comme anouilh et
nous arrivons au terme notre voyage
façon très vite en effet par moscou
c'est un très grand pays où il fait
souvent très froid est là bas le père
noël a beaucoup de mérite
on dit que pour l'instant il n'est pas
très riche mais rassurez vous les petits
enfants russes ne seront pas oubliés
d'ailleurs dans le monde entier comme à
new york du club ici il faut souhaiter
que cette nuit papa noël n'oublie
personne
le papa noël n'oublie personne pour que
demain matin on puisse danser devant les
jouets la même ronde dans tous les pays
du nous allons maintenant nous dans le
midi à vallauris pour y retrouver une
petite fille barbara si barbara a été
bien sa petite jeanne pourparlers elle a
que deux ans mais il s'amuse à vallauris
et il ce soir
oui avec ta soeur on va manger beaucoup
de bonnes choses comme tout l'effectif
en france j'espère et je vais profiter
maintenant on peut vous souhaiter à tous
et bien sûr at one douce le très joyeux
noël
e
lui seul de nuit quand j'ai su y est
mais
qui est
sourire
dans tes yeux tandis que
non
seul
mais
ça
les eaux
le refus de tulle or dans notre famille
des sources
il est un personnage que nous aimons
beaucoup
seul le gros nounours de la chanson il
est très difficile à rencontrer mais ce
soir ce nord d'ordinaire quand les
grandes personnes ne traite d'ours ça ça
ne plaît pas tellement n'apprécie pas
beaucoup mais quand ce sont les enfants
qui n'auront pas d'entraîneur qu'il veut
font là mais d'après n'est pas on
m'appelait vendre personne je ne mettrai
pas de chansons pour pour les enfants la
pelouse n'est pas écrit de noël non plus
je pense qu'on peut s'arranger je pense
que je peux chanter une chanson qui
paiera aux enfants le petit joueur de
flûte au même née la musique au château
pour la grâce de ses chansons le roi lui
offrit un blason genève veut pas être
noble répondit le
croque notes avec un blason à la clé mon
là se mettrait à gonfler on dirait par
tout le pays
le joueur de flûte a trahi le petit
joueur de flûte au fis la révérence au
château cents à moiry sans pain chemin
sans gloire il se mit en chemin vers son
clocher sache aux mineurs c'est pas et
sa promise
nul ne puise dans le pays
le joueur de flûte à trahir et dieu
reconnaissent pour siens le brave petit
musicien bien je souhaite jouer noël à
tous les petits et même aux grands
débuts aux ours poussoir des enfants
vous aimez noël
oui
enfin je vous entends vous allez mettre
vos petites chaussures dans la cheminée
ce soir mais pour le moment le père noël
a déposé auprès de l'arbre qui hélas pas
des joujoux pour vous allez vite voir
aller
chaussures cuba qui passe quand même
temps mon coeur qui bat qui fend en tête
au jour 4
je ne
la joie à volonté
la joie de la joie dans mon soulier 4 et
j'espère qu'il va occuper
jacky pas beau show cars
enfin son autonomie
tant d'autres mal an
c'est mon cas
merci alain donnât lorsque j'étais un
tout petit ourson le soir de noël moment
ours et papa ours aiment et fredonné une
chanson une chanson que des générations
et des générations de petits ours
connaissent bien comme tous les
petits-enfants bossoirs kino pour sa
maintenance
eh bien puisque je suis là ce soir je
profite de l'occasion pour souhaiter à
tous les petits enfants un joyeux noël
la neige étant son manteau blanc et les
yeux levés vers le ciel un jeu
nous les petits enfants avant de fermer
les paupières font-ils dernière prix
si papa noël quand tu descendras du ciel
des jouets par milliers n'oublie pas mon
petit soulier
mais avant de partir il faudra bien tu
couvres hui dehors tu dois savoir si
froid c'est un peu à cause de moi il me
tarde tant que le jour le rêve fou noir
si tu m'as apporté
tous les vosges aux jo je bois doré
echoes autre monde
et
ben
on ne l'est pas mon petit soulier d or
non
eh ben tu vois nounours moi qui te
prenais pour un journaliste sérieux
nous avons choisi cinq chevaux ânes ou
deux pour le tiercé de demain il ya
trois là qui ne court pas tu vois comme
ça ni toi ni moi fait pour être des
pronostiqueurs voici la fin de cette
édition un peu spéciale j'espère que
vous l'avez aimée en tout cas au nom des
actualités télévisées c'est à dire au
nom des journalistes des reporters
cameramen des ingénieurs du son de tous
nos camarades technicien je vous
souhaite un joyeux un très joyeux un
très bon noël
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir merci